are you you're already turning before
the person wrapped your wrist or if
you're already raced in there is that
some form of either over a breach and
over that
training the right of the room
you mean when you're moving what appears
to be ahead of them I think structured
like already I think two things in what
you're talking about so one thing is
doing kihon Wazza
and mikey one was a should be considered
a conditioning or organization training
it should not be considered a self
defense and that means then that I'm
going to be more concerned with what I'm
doing and then even more concerned with
how I'm doing it and definitely very
very very little concern over it did I
throw them or did I pin them I'm so
concerned with what and how and even
when that's subjectively the throw or
the pin should be experienced more as a
coincidence not as a conclusion but most
people don't see techniques that way
they don't seek Eman was it that way and
even amongst those who have been
indoctrinated with this old Budo
paradigm this Confucian way of training
right as to move as if you already had
the skill so to be as if training even
those who are indoctrinated in that the
ego focuses in on the conclusion and
everything else becomes almost an
obstacle such that if you if I why will
i turn my hips more if i could knock
them down right here and so turning your
hips more is an obstacle in that in the
sense that it's
delay to the thing you want which is to
throw them down we had that in
yesterday's drill where people would not
rotate their hips fully right well if
you don't rotate your hips fully then
you don't develop the skill of hip
rotation you don't develop the skill of
maintaining structure in the face of
centrifugal energy you don't mean you
don't cultivate the skill of utilizing a
single point for your weight shifting
what for example what most of you are
doing is traditionally a no-no one of
the very few known OHS shared across
traditional martial arts which there's
no double weighted don't double weight
don't double pivot do you understand
don't turn with your center of gravity
between your contact points on there
that's a no-no shared there's not many
things shared there's always variations
and some school thinks they got a secret
this or that but that's like one of them
no double pivot is wrong it's wrong
because kinesiology is wrong and easy
illogically it doesn't allow for
rotation and stability to pivot on two
points to have your way between two
points is to lose stability which is
what you know when you see a figure
skater who's biting it I always used to
watch Figure Skating and then go wow how
many decades has they've been trying
that damn ass move and he get to the
Olympics and it's still like 5050 if
they're gonna make the jump
there's always strange to me but later
you realize it's very hard to do your
turn over where your mass is all in
alignment over the point of rotation is
very hard to do and this the tiniest
variation where you're not then you're
gonna bite it that was happening
yesterday people were double pivoting
double weighted so I want to understand
kihon in that sense of a conditioning
in the organization training drill so in
that sense yes you do Keo in Lhasa you
don't yet have a great sense of body
organization Center utilization start it
like that
start the technique already in the kind
of you know plank do you know what I
mean the same kind of organization we're
always trying to get start like that
that'll be better off and then work to
maintain that throughout the technique
don't lose it well the second they touch
your hand because your mind goes to that
part and you lose just a consciousness
of yourself in your own organization
right and then don't lose it because now
you get hungry and your desire to throw
and your mind goes to that and you lose
self conscious again and you lose the
organization so it's helpful to start
like that and you should which is one of
the things I sit down you're well at
least they're organized more than you
know then I'm gonna let you're wrong
you're incorrect as sabaki go because I
can work more with that where the other
thing when you don't have the proper
body organization in really your Aikido
is based primarily on geometry
you know like levers and fulcrums that
it's just crap I don't even call that
Aikido that's not Aikido you you could
you could get a fishing pole and and
start casting fly-fishing on the net and
you would you know on the mat you would
be as close to Aikido as if you're
Aikido was just fulcrum some levers I
wouldn't
I wouldn't go your what the hell's with
the fly-fishing
you're just as far away okay so yeah
start like that I think that's a good
place to start but the other thing
you're kind of getting to in Japanese is
musubi this is a kind of time or uniting
or binding of two separate things to
make one like a harmony tying of your
shoelaces you know you make one or at
L&L barbecue you have a musubi where you
unite spam seaweed and rice right that's
the idea
so that musubi is the is often referred
to as a blending so no no contesting of
space of matter they don't push on their
push that kind of thing and at the
beginning when you first start that
concept should and more easily should be
manifested and is more easily manifested
when you're blending material things so
like in Thai no Henco your your grip
it's a doggy azúcar is blended with
Nagas movement Nagi is not suitable
crash into your grid or do some weird
fulcrum thing to your thumb right this
to me that's a waste of the drill
[Music]
but as you go further you begin to
realize and some of you if you were very
sincere in your self observation skills
you would realize that you are actually
clashing they are hitting you there's
sometimes there's a sound right and if
not you can feel a jerk or you have to
wait right you have to wait for the
pinning of your legs which is happening
from them clashing into your arm you
have to wait for that energy to go up or
sometimes you don't do the IDI Miyoshi
because you can't move anymore forward
because you've clashed with them those
are all signs of that and and why is
that happening because musubi cannot
truly exist at a material level first
musubi the uniting of things has to
happen at an immaterial level it must
take place by at least the manifestation
of intention the intention has no matter
to it and for you to even be operating
at that level of intention you're going
to have to have connection you're going
to have to have union prior to even that
I'm just saying if you don't have a by
intention you you're basically you're
gonna have to redeploy right you're not
going to be able to blend with that
thing that's coming in so that's why for
example you have things like zansheng
maintain connection at the conclusion of
your previous rep so that you have that
connection across the time and space
between you and then you have a chance
to do it so in weapons too when we draw
on the holster you know out of the
holster that's that's possible not
because I'm trying to get ahead of you
you actually formed the intention and I
actually am United with you
with the intention and we do that all
the time you really do that all the time
there's not one technique that you're
not really doing that especially when
you start leaving the static versions of
key horn when you're starting to get for
example in G you Wazza if you're not
United if you have not already achieved
the musubi between you and that person
that's some immaterial level uniting or
blending or musubi generating the sube
with their strike or their kick or
whatever after that it's not going to
happen
so it only looks like you're moving
ahead and you're not really moving first
for a head and as you train more you'll
start to see that usually it gets first
first experience of it or usually a
beginner student will experience it
first as you can and do so in the
following way it'll be some training
some sort of GU was a variation and
[Music]
you'll throw a strike where I am NOT
asked and you'll ask yourself why in the
F that I throw that strike I knew it
would be but I moved when you had the
intention and it's gonna take you about
three-quarters of a second to change
plans and and so I remembered that as
as the as it okay with my teachers
you're like you throw it and you already
go ah crap things they moved out of the
way because they were already United
with you and if you saw the little
demonstration there that is all I'm
doing it's really cheating because they
keep going where I want them to go but I
make where they're going where I want
them to go because I'm not there anymore
you get that and so it looks easy but
that part of uniting across space and
time that part's not easy that takes a
long time to train which is why for
example when we do weapons to training I
have that person drawing in front of you
I don't you get I want you to get used
to what that looks like okay you're
you're doing that training sometimes
when we do the movement drills when
you're only allowed to defend yourself
and you can only use angle of daeviation
and that's that's about you getting used
to what does it look like what does
attacking body look like even doing
title Henkel all burned over and over
again what does a linear progression
towards me look like and feel like your
body is starting to gain that capacity
for connection without actually touching
the downside of this is that a lot of
people will look at it from afar and
because they did not experience that
moment of why the hell did I throw that
punch they look at it and go I guess you
just throw punches to the side of
someone and and and so then they start
training like that so you go to this
dojo all around the world and people are
throwing punches way to the side and way
early the Naga is is way deviating and
they call it leading right and somehow
that makes it right I thought it was
musubi
if I'm leading I'm pulling it's a weird
thing that happens but it but that
leading and that you know that leading
has no Marshall application whatsoever
the guy's just gonna readjust his aim
okay boom you know and not be right out
you see that a lot I love watching when
Aikido people you know who don't
understand these traditional concepts
and they misunderstand them and come up
with these concepts like leading and and
they trained with punching off to the
side and they go ahead and move and they
wonder why the other guy why aren't you
why aren't you following me you know an
extension of that problem too is when
did not win that you have run circles
circles around the the nage like how
many 360s are we gonna do here what the
hell with my in a vortex what's going on
you don't know talking about like
especially I can eat me not get it okay
is like just running around and and the
the noggin is just turning around like
there's a barbershop pole you know in
the middle and then where where and why
would that ever apply ever write to me
spiritually that that's the exact
opposite of what I'm trying to achieve
because musubi occurs at the absence of
self and just barbershop whole idea is
like I am the god of the universe right
and I will evolve around me why just
because right it's the exact opposite of
what Buddha is aiming at which is why if
you don't revolve around them they get
pissed and like a angry Greek god they
want to throw lightning at you right
because you didn't play their game with
them it's a very strange world in IQ
a big part of that strangeness so don't
confuse stick with this musubi get your
body organization first and then try to
understand musubi first initially as a
material communion and then as an
immaterial communion just keep training
and you'll you'll get there we trained
in it we're getting you there even like
that week you've done my ankle I just
need you to get used to people coming at
you yeah we need to have that class
we've done it in the past but I finally
put the young a you Miyoshi video which
is how do I move forward okay and then
begin Tenkaichi is going to be hard
right rotate and it's a question how do
I move forward while being grounded and
how do I turn well being grounded or how
do I move forward while being grounded
and having my upper torso body
organization right be a part of it or
again how do I turn be grounded such
that I can have my upper body
organization
so we haven't had that video yet but hey
what do you know about East Asian
philosophy its Yin there's Yin and
there's young okay and inside of young
there's what a little bit of Yin and
inside of Yin there's a little bit of
okay and so they're basically the same
essences but coming from a different
perspective so if you take the what
we're calling the mid-foot waiting right
and we establish that in an Annie angle
or an ankle angle that goes from right
angle to right no further than the toes
remember that okay and we use that to
move forward we're gonna use that to
turn now when you do that if I was using
that to move forward I was establishing
a weighted single point that I was using
to propel me forward right and what did
I say we need to turn properly a
weighted single point okay so the in
Tenkasi is going to be okay establish a
weighted single point and we're gonna do
it using annotation so you you already
know it but it's one of those things
right - no it's not enough right I have
to go know it right and I have to be
able to do it so we need reps okay well
you could figure it out and we have
covered it in the past
we just haven't covered
nor have we put it on video babe it'll
be there for you to see but if you go
back to the young video I think you
could piece it together because either
there when we've done the Tenkaichi and
the ten Connolly and all that stuff we
might be able to figure it out now what
is the knee bend what is too far what
are the limits of the of the ankle angle
right where's my weight supposed to be
all that's explained in the young video
and if you tie that to the drills that
you've done in the past it's very
sensei's drills you'll figure you should
be able to figure but we'll soon get it
on video we were gonna do it tonight but
when the way I was watching you guys
take time to hand code we needed to work
more on this body organization
yeah I think I've been stuck on thinking
understand it rather than just I think
it's related I think in some ways an
over intellectualization of our our
existence is about a type of
unreconciled fear and I think an
unreconciled fear is often an obstacle
to faith so I think there is some
relationship there but you know I don't
think it's necessarily a modern human
problem it just might be a modern
problem I mean a problem a human problem
because if you look at the historical
record there there are constant stories
where the cook for the old the old know
nothing
you know beggar woman knows more than
the learnin scholar month okay so even
today in a Zen temple the cook is a
place of you know high ranking high
cultural capital but that's because a
long time ago there were stories that
you know pointing out that you don't
it's not enough to just have title and
certificates and to be able to float the
passages that understanding is beyond
that and some and in some ways contrary
to that that is a sentiment we repeat
here that's why we don't do the ranks
and the black bells you know passport
books and certificates and all that crap
because it gets in the way of a pure
practice right and and in the way the
way it does it is that it displaces the
pure practice so somehow everyone makes
the jump from the certificate that was
supposed to represent understanding to
the certificate is
understanding and so we started you know
you want to start anything nowadays ago
what certificates do you have right
instead of like a start talking start
talking to me
let me see can you do something let me
see no one will ever do that nowadays I
mean we are we are such a symbolic
culture in the sense that man we don't
have anything real we only have symbols
that stand for something that was real a
long time ago with someone else in a
galaxy far far away and that's enough
right and no one even problematizes that
yeah you can get a certificate in the
weekend or an hour or four hours or or
you know online and so we we run things
with that in mind that it's about
understanding right I use that joke
canoing because the Greek word gnosis is
about knowledge but knowledge that you
have a realization about that it's in
your blood it's in your bones in your
tissue so my professor at the University
used to use that word to draw a
distinction between knowing something
and and what we're trying to say with
this word understanding or being or
achievement or realization he would say
not know but to good know is a reference
to gnosis GN
sis that's a tough one right
that's why silence is often used when we
talked about that a couple days hey shut
up shut up stop it shut up and just move
and train okay
we'll talk afterwards right we're
talking now we'll talk afterwards but
shut the F up prior to driving here as
you training many many religious systems
spiritual systems utilize a vow of
silence precisely because our intellect
is in our speech and in that speech then
is our ego and our ego attachment and is
our obstacle towards good knowing so
shut up learn to do that there's
absolutely no reason right why do you
even have to ask the question like I'm
fine this is a question answer period
but why really did you have to ask how
do I do ten kailashi what did what did
you have what's another way of doing it
of learning it watching watching and
doing it let's say I explained it to you
are you any closer no I can give you the
degrees and everything you wouldn't be
able to do it and if you could you
wouldn't be able to do it under stress
right so let's stick to these other ways
that we learn watching submitting
humility self displacement silence those
are the paths to good knowing
thinking waiting for answers having
things makes sense
these are obstacles to true seekers and
only the false seeker has a problem with
that statement you put in a couple false
seekers here they'll they'll don't hate
me
you're gonna start checking their
wallets and make sure their bank account
is still right and see if their pants
are still on but they don't know they
don't know they haven't they haven't
truly saw enough they haven't truly run
into the problem of the limitations of
the intellect because they were gamblers
and you can't everyone can dabble
everything right at a certain beginning
at a certain point in time everyone
played the guitar just as good as Stevie
Ray Vaughn at a certain point everyone
was that as good as him at that certain
point so dabbling does work but only for
one so practice silence and observation
you'll get further